the financial crisis of 2008 threatened
the world economy with recession but
China took measures against the economic
slump the state bought billions of euros
worth of raw materials and machines
including from Germany to invest in
infrastructure and industry within five
years China's economic productivity
doubled but how long will China continue
to fuel the world economy the biggest
boom scenes over China is over producing
steel cement and coal it sells a surplus
on the world market at dumping prices
and China's currency has plummeted
fearing a crash many wealthy Chinese
have put their money in other currencies
outside the country accelerating the
fall of the renminbi China's growth was
financed with borrowed money and the
country's debt has quadrupled to an
estimated 28 trillion dollars if China
loses its credit the financial system is
in trouble and not just in China a crash
in the world's second-largest economy
could imperil the whole world as much as
the crisis of 2008 did